this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armies museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons
from throughout history and today he's
going to be breaking down the guns of
2017's call of duty world war ii
to see how accurately the period
weaponry is portrayed in the game
there are no optical sights in use in
the second world war
get your modern warfare out of my world
war ii let us know if there are any
other games guns or mechanics you want
jonathan to break down in the comments
section below
make sure you subscribe for more videos
like this and if you want to support
jonathan's work and the royal armouries
museum
check out the links in the description
of this video alright
time to hit the battlefield of call of
duty world war ii
and pausing because we may as well do
the ping
one of the most iconic features of the
m1
rifle of the garand as it's long been
known is that
ping sound but even when they're being
cycled
rather than fired you will get that ping
sound it's the
fundamental to how the weapon works so
you have a clip
of eight rounds the whole thing goes
into the weapon
stays in the gun until the last round's
fired and then the mechanism
punts out the empty click and that bit
of tempered steel
is what oscillates as it's thrown out of
the gun
and makes that iconic ringing sound
and the other thing i'm noticing here is
this
aiming down the sights view that that we
have and the rear sight looks a bit
funky it's this massive sort of rounded
ring almost looks like a curtain ring
and that's not
what the m1s rear sight looks like
but the actual aperture itself this is
such a minor detail and it's very likely
a gameplay thing
if they if if it was modeled correctly
it would be quite hard to get the
realistic view
because your eye automatically focuses
through
that ring and it actually looks a little
bit like we see on screen but
just like in real life in the game
you're not really focusing on what shape
the rear sight is when you're shooting
at the gems
causing unlike the modern age there
aren't that many accessories for
rifles of the second world war period uh
the bayonet is
an important one another one that's very
rarely depicted in games
is the grenade launcher um today we're
used to thinking of a grenade launcher
either as a
stand-alone weapon or as something that
fits under the barrel of your weapon so
the grenade you see in the game
is a fragmentation anti-personnel type
grenade
this one is a practice version of an
anti-tank
type of grenade and it just slips over
the spigot and with
special grenade launching cartridges
this thing just gets punted off the end
so you don't see them particularly often
and
your primary anti-tank weapons in the
second world war become
shoulder-fired weapons things like the
bazooka they're far more effective so
it's
always interesting for me to see rifle
grenades depicted in
games
pausing the next weapon i'm seeing is
the
what people tend to call the ppsh-41 but
i'm trying to get into the habit of
calling the papasha because that's how
it should really be said but it's
another iconic submachine gun of the
period there are so many
of this period it's the heyday really of
the submachine gun it's a very high rate
of fire
from memory higher than what we're
seeing in this footage
it's a good 900 plus rounds per minute
so that high
high rate of fire combined with a 71
round
drum magazine so it's a lot of firepower
in a small package
what we see on in the game is not this
magazine at all the magazine we see in
the game is this one
you don't need to modify the weapon you
don't need a different magazine well or
anything like that
it is completely interchangeable and
it's a lower capacity obviously you can
see that right away
but it's a lot less heavier and bulky
than the drum mag as the months wore on
during the war you're going to find more
of these magazines in use
it is a little odd seeing german
soldiers
in 1944 in western europe with
soviet submachine guns probably not
impossible that they might have got
their hands on those
but it's a lot less likely in this
theater that you're going to come across
captured russian pakistan i suspect it's
just that the developers wanted it in
the game
and i can't blame them it's an excellent
sub machine gun
and an amazing piece of history the
artillery gun
get some charges on those guns i've just
grabbed the
the mauser chanel foyer which is the
select fire
and semi-automatic c96
mouse epistle the first thing you notice
of course in the gameplay footage is
that we've got one in each hand
and we're running and gunning with them
fair enough it's a game
it's not really that practical to do
that this thing on its own
without the buttstock is pretty much
impossible to aim
never mind one-handed never mind both at
once but
the way you want to use it is as a
submachine gun you fit the shoulder
stock which is also the holster
because now you've got four points of
contact
shoulder sheet this hand and then the
other hand on the magazine well
and you can actually buy a short burst
quite effectively depiction wise it's a
bit off
the hammer it appears to be solid
whereas all
broom handle hammers have cone hammers
because they're shaped like phones the
big emission
is the selector switch the heart of this
thing is
as a package is the selected switch to
switch it to automatic
we only see the weapon fires on
automatic and we don't see a switch
which is um
doesn't really make any sense so that's
that's the channel for you makes perfect
sense for the setting
it's very cool and why wouldn't you use
two at once
when we're talking about entertainment
on the second floor pausing
the thompson gun um you cannot have a
second world war game
without a thompson gun and there are a
few different variants to choose from
so these guys have chosen both at the
same time so it's perfectly plausible to
see a gun of this rough
shape in use with a drum magazine but
what we see here is not the 1928
model thompson it is an m1 or an m1a1
so here is what we're really seeing here
which is the m1 this is an m1a1
very quickly no cuts in the receiver for
the drum mag
very very obviously if you if you know
your thompson's
doesn't have the cocking handle on the
top of the weapon anymore it's on the
side
the only real issue with the depiction
of the weapon other than it being
the wrong variant is the reload it's
what's known as an open bolt
gun so it fires from this position which
is something that a lot of games miss so
you pull the trigger
the bolt goes forward changes around
fires it and then
comes back to that position when it goes
click which is the sound you don't want
to hear
the bolt is going to be forward so when
you
swap over your magazine you can't just
pull the trigger nothing's getting
chambered and fired what you have to do
is reclock the weapon just like in any
reload animation you've seen of
an ak it's magazine on recock and the
game
gets that wrong unfortunately
this is a really interesting weapon to
have put into
world war ii it's an interesting weapon
to appear in the
in the war because it's essentially a
double barrel
shotgun it's a sporting weapon so this
was the model 30 as it's correctly
designated in the game
was designed based on a double barrel
side by side
sporting shotgun for luftwaffe
crews so that they would have a capable
survival
as well as self-defense weapon if they
were damned
uh it's pretty well depicted in the game
the the modeling wise
uh in terms of the break action although
that's pretty standard
shotgun stuff the first thing you spot
of course
probably is the third barrel and in the
game you very clearly see
the third barrel in fact the character
even puts his finger over that
third cartridge to stop it from being
ejected because it's not been fired yet
and in single player it doesn't get
fired at all there is an unlock
i gather for the very long
rifle cartridge because this is a rifled
barrel underneath the other two barrels
so it does feature in the game but not
in single player the other
interesting thing is and people may have
wondered about this one
at one point we see the sight flip up
now what that is is switching to rifle
mode what looks
to be a safety on the rear here
is in fact converting the switching the
fire the firing pins from the
shotgun cartridges to the rifle
cartridge a little mechanism
flips up your long-range sight the
only criticism i might have is the way
it's modeled is
you can see that rifle rear sight part
way down the barrel
doesn't move and it does move on this
one they've added a second sight
closer to the player's eye that actually
flips up
and i'm pretty sure that the developers
have just had to
put a rear sight further to the rear and
they've just left
this one modeled on the gun on you go
this was a weird one i remember this
mission pretty pretty clearly
the grease gun the m3 grease gun being
used as a as a weapon of stealth is
on the face of it a bit surprising but
suppressed grease guns did exist this
was designed for the
office of strategic services now the big
red flag as it were
for the realism side is seeing the guys
quick detaching and reattaching
the suppressor that's what kind of drew
me out of it a little bit because in
real life if you wanted to switch from
an unsuppressed
grease gun to a suppressed grease gun
you'd have to throw away
your suppressed grease gun that kind of
quick detach suppressor was not
really a thing yet in the second world
war the gun itself i think is
is well modeled it's the original m3 not
the m3a1 so it has this sort of
comedy crank handle
locking handle which is one of the main
features that was changed for the
a1
well done always interesting to look at
how suppressed weapons
are depicted in terms of their report
their sound
in the game versus reality
this would have been a very quiet weapon
the problem with it and things like the
mark
ii s sten gun so open bolts submachine
guns with suppressors on them
is that the bolt moving back and forth
makes quite a noise
as it is so in the dead of night in the
middle of someone's house
you're still going to hear but you're
still you're getting that twice you're
getting it
blown back and then clucking forward
again most suppressed weapons will also
have some sort of a pop from the muzzle
equivalent to an air pistol at the very
least yeah it's not it's not it's not
wildly
inaccurate like the old hollywood sort
of laser gun sound but it's maybe a bit
too quiet
the mp40 it's one of those weapons you
can't really not have
it's the archetypal bad guy's gun
so the way it's depicted in the game is
there's not much to say about really
they've done a good job the very low
recoil of the weapon is effectively
modeled pretty well
this thing's got a tremendously good
spring buffer in it
and it's kind of like a sewing machine
just sits there clacking away
14. i can't let the clip of the optical
sight go
i'm afraid sorry guys there are no
optical sights
no reflex sights like like we see here
in use on small arms in the second world
war
what this is is a couple of decades of
modern warfare
bleeding through to our second world war
so um
get your modern warfare out of my world
war ii i suppose is what i would say
there
causing the mp43 mp44
sgg44 they're all functionally the same
gun
the the concept here really was a
submachine gun on steroids
it was to scale up the submachine gun
and its little pistol cartridge not very
damaging
to something more more powerful or if
you want to look at the other way
it's scaling down the rifle the
self-loading rifle
to something more compact with a fully
automatic capability
i'm sure people wouldn't another verse
to seeing a real
stg this example i've chosen to make a
specific point
which is that some optical sights were
in use
on weapons like this in the second world
war what i like about this
footage actually i can't remember how i
use the gun in the game it's been a
while
but um is the way we see the rifle used
as it was intended
so although we don't have switchable
fire modes in this game
we see single shots because it's slow
enough that you can pull off single
shots
we see short bursts which which give you
more sort of stopping
power effectively and a greater chance
of hitting and we see automatic fire
like a submachine gun and that's
exactly what this was designed for to do
all of those things germany really
nailed it with
the assault rifle first time which is
pretty impressive
but a bit too late in the war to make
any significant
difference
okay guys thanks very much for watching
this breakdown of the weapons of call of
duty world war ii
if you would like to support the museum
and help us keep doing
this sort of thing with our friends at
gamespot there is a donation link
down below in the description for the
video no pressure at all
but we would appreciate any donations
that you feel you can afford
thanks again
[Music]
you